patch 5.01 dropped last week and there
were quite a few agent changes phoenix
and yoru finally received some
much-needed buffs but all everyone is
talking about is ko
why well his fragment grenade no longer
requires line of sight to do damage you
might be wondering why this is an issue
and it's because killjoy is now
absolutely useless she's already fallen
out of the meta because chamber is so
damn broken but now you can destroy her
seven point ultimate through a wall with
an ability that costs 200 credits
yeah it's
one of valerian's game designers raikou
did comment on the change saying that
they took a bet because they liked the
reliability of the zone for the base
case but if it becomes too egregious
then they'll find a fix find a fix how
about we fix chamber first